mes chers collègues je vous propose de
commencer cette audition très très
attendue je
voudrais je voudrais excuser quelques
instants un certain nombre de nos
collègues qui vont arriver parce qu'en
même temps il y a voilà il y a un autre
sujet traité dans un autre lieu donc on
va être rejoint par d'avantage de nos
collègues tout à l'heure mes chers
collègues nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir aujourd'hui monsieur Luc
Rémont qui est le candidat proposé par
le Président de la République aux
fonctions de président directeur général
du groupe EDF c'est évidemment euh un
poste et une mission extrêmement
importante et pour laquelle notre
commission évidemment est très attentive
je vous rappelle que cette nomination ne
peut pas ne peut intervenir qu'après
audition devant les commissions
compétentes et de l'Assemblée nationale
et du Sénat cette audition est publique
elle est ouverte à la presse et elle est
retransmise sur notre site Internet et
donc je salue à la fois bien sûr les
journalistes mais j'en suis sûr les
salariés deedf qui doivent être à
l'écoute de cette audition elle sera
suivie d'un vote qui se déroulera je
vous le rappelle aussi à bulletin secret
et je rappelle que les délégations de
votes ne sont pas autorisés donc ceux
qui seront présents voteront uniquement
euh et je vous rappelle que le
dépoulement doit être effectué
simultanément avec l'Assemblée nationale
l'Assemblée nationale entendant Monsieur
Raymond après nous nous dépouillerons
les bulletins à la mi-journée en
application du 5e alinéa de l'article 13
de la Constitution le président de la
République ne pourrait procéder à votre
nomination Monsieur Raymond si
l'addition des votes négatifs exprimés
dans les deux assemblée représentait au
moins 3/5e des suffrages exprimés avant
de passer Laer la parole à notre
collègue Daniel gré qui est président du
groupe d'étude énergie et rapporteur sur
cette nomination je souhaiterais
rappeler solennellement ici la gravité
de la crise énergétique que nous
traversons la guerre russe en Ukraine a
évidemment une incidence considérable
sur le marché gazier et par voie de
conséquence sur celui de l'électricité
en raison du principe du coût marginal
qui les lit de plus notre production
d'électricité nucléaire est au plus bas
nous en reparlerons avec une perspective
de moins de 300 tawh pour 2022 cont tenu
du phénomène désormais bien connu de de
corrosion sous contrainte qui a touché
30 réacteurs je rappelle que nous avons
été la première instance parlementaire a
évoqué directement et précocément ce
sujet ainsi que ses implications sur
notre sécurité d'approvisionnement en
février dè février dans le cadre des
tavau de notre collègue précisément
Daniel grmier de Jean-Pierre Moga et de
Jean-Jacques Michot dans ce contexte
très dégradé on peut noter des
hésitations du gouvernement c'est le
moin que l'on puisse dire on légifère
dans le désordre on l'a dit et redit
plusieurs fois dans cette commission et
dans et dans notre assemblée alors qu'il
aurait fallu commencer par la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
nous donner le cap puis par les j'allais
dire les éléments de d'exécution nous
avons commencé à l'envers le projet de
loi d'accélération des énergie
renouvelable ne comportait pas jusqu'à
hier soir de disposition sur
l'hydroélectricité qui est pourtant
notre première source d'énergie
renouvelable et la présentation au
Conseil des ministres du projet
d'accélération de l'énergie nucléaire
qui nous intéresse beaucoup a été
reportée laissant en suspend la relance
de cette filière annoncée en février
dernier mais aussi avant les élections
présidentielles en octobre de l'année
dernière enfin nous sommes dans le flou
s'agissant de notre cap énergétique
l'objectif de réduction de 50 % de notre
production nucléaire la fermeture de 12
réacteurs au-delà de ceux de Fessenheim
étant je vous le rappelle mes chers
collègues toujours inscrit dans la loi
et dans le règlement ça me paraît un peu
ubuesque ce manque de cap est aussi
palpable dans les relations entre le
gouvernement et le groupe EDF donc je
viens au groupe EDF qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui votre prédécesseur
Jean-Bernard Lévi a été mis publiquement
en cause par le Président de la
République le 6 septembre dernier sur un
manque d'anticipation la relance du
nucléire en particulier pour permettre
aux opérateurs économiques d'anticiper
c'est au pouvoir politique de leur
donner le cap et force de constater
au-delà des effets d'annonce que le
gouvernement a beaucoup louvoyé nous
nous l'avons dit dans une lettre ouverte
d'ailleurs avec notre collègue Daniel
gréier et le gouvernement a multiplié
les décisions qui nous semblent
défavorables au groupe EDF la fermeture
des réacteurs de Fessenheim en mars et
juin 2020 c'est 1,8 Gow et 2000 emplois
directs qui sont concernés le relèvement
de l'arê en février 2022 c'est 10
milliards d'euros autant de moyens au
moins alors que le groupe est grévé je
le rappelle d'une dette de 43 milliards
d'euros et confronté à un mur
d'investissement pour relancer le
nucléaire accélérer le renouveelable
l'équation est donc très complexe et la
nationalisation du groupe très flou
euh et ça ne à notre avis ne règle rien
du tout à défaut d'action
gouvernementale notre commission a gelé
le plafond de laarenne à 120wh releveré
son montant à 49 € du mgawh nonans en
difficulté 49,50 € pardon dans le cadre
du projet de loi de protection sur le
pouvoir d'achat c'est donc une question
à laquelle nous sommes très inentifs
voilà Monsieur Raymond le contexte dans
lequel vous arrivez qui est un contexte
de crise un contexte d'urgence avec une
conjoncture chaotique et des chantiers
titanesque voilà si votre nomination est
confirmée par le Parlement vous seriez
en quelque sorte un capitaine en pleine
tempête voilà mais doté les vrais il me
semble d'une solide expérience nous
avions dissigné votre prédécesseur à six
reprises ces dernières années je ne
doute pas que nous serons appelés à nous
revoir en cas de confirmation voilà
voilà pour le contexte général et avant
de vous laisser répondre je vais donner
la parole à Daniel grimier qui va vous
poser les premières
questions merci madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues Monsieur Raymond
l'audition qui nous réunit aujourd'hui
est tout sauf
formelle au contraire elle est
éminemment stratégique car l'enjeu est
de redonner un cap au groupe EDF dans la
situation de crise énergétique et de la
dette financière rappelée par notre
présidente ce cap il sera déterminant
pour relancer le nucléaire et accélérer
le renouvelable mais Monsieur Raymond il
va plus loin parce que ce cap il sera
déterminant sur le fait que les ménag
pourront supporter le coût énergétique
il sera déterminant sur la compétitivité
de nos entreprises la relocalisation des
productions industrielle dans notre pays
quelque part au niveau de la commission
économique nous disons souvent il y a
dans un pays la souveraineté alimentaire
mais la souveraineté énergétique est
quasiment au même niveau ma première
interrogation concerne monsieur Raymon
vous êtes diplômé de l'École
polytechnique vous avez été conseiller
ministériel au début des années 2000
vous avez travaillé à la Direction
générale de l'armement et à celle du
Trésor vous avez exercé dans le secteur
bancaire puis intégré chezir électrique
en 2014 donct vous êtes actuellement le
directeur général des opérations
internationale ce solide parcours est
toutefois un peu éloigné des
missions de production et de fourniture
d'énergie t que celle du groupe EDF en
quoi votre parcours peut-il vous aider
dans vos fonctions de plus son lit dans
la presse que vous auriez conseillé la
vente de la branche énergie d'astom à
général électrique lorsque vous étiez
dans le secteur bancaire est-ce le cas
et quel enseignement en
tirez-vous
comment ma deuxème question
interrogation concerne le groupe EDF ces
dernières années ont été successivement
annoncé par le gouvernement le projet
Hercule devenu grand EDF puis la
nationisation du groupe quel est votre
point de vue sur l'organisation de
groupe une réforme est-elle toujours à
l'agenda avec une CISS des activités
nucléaires et renouvelable pensez-vous
que la Commission européenne puisse
accepter en l'absence de réforme une
nouvelle régulation de nucléaire
existant et le règlement du contentieux
hydroélectrique votre prédécesseur avait
appelé à la révision de l'arine qualifié
par lui de poisson et à la mise à l'abri
des concessions via un mécanisme de
quasi régie êtes-vous sur la même ligne
et la nationalisation vous semble-t-elle
suffisante pour répondre au défis
financiers économiques et sociaux du
groupe 3è interrogation monsieur Ron a
trait à la relance du nucléaire notre
commission a fait adopter à la cas
unanimité en juillet un rapport très
complet intitulé nucléaire et hydrogène
l'urgence d'agir tout est dit dans le le
titre dans ce rapport nous appelons à
redresser rapidement la production du
parc existant pouvez-vous nous rassurer
sur le phénomène de corrosion sous
contrainte quelle est déjà votre analyse
sur ce sujet Quelles sont vos prévisions
de production et de
calendrier dans ce domaine sur la remise
en route avez-vous mis en œuvre le
procédé pensez-vous que le procédé de de
contrôle par ultrason plus rapide des
réacteurs sera g généralisé et permettra
d'aller encore bien plus vite quel est
l'impact financier sur le programme du
grand carénage et qu'en est-il de la
mise en service de la centrale de
flamandville que nous avons eu le
plaisir de visiter au niveau de la
commission des affaires économiques le
10 juillet dernier de plus dans ce
rapport nous plaidons pour un mix
énergétique majoritairement nucléaire
d'ici 2005 afin de réaliser concrètement
le scénario n03 de RTE pour se faire
nous souhaitons la commande ferme non
pas de 6 mais de 14 pr et de 4 GW de SMR
nous soulevons aussi quelques impensé de
la relance annoncée du nucléaire pour
RTE il manque 3 pr en l'absence de
prolongation au-delà de 60 ans
puisqueaujourd'hui nous avons toujours
pas la réponse et 9 pr dans l'hypothèse
d'une réindustriation fond que nous
souhaitons tous quel scénario et quel
nombre de réacteurs ont votre préférence
de plus il faut convenir d'un modèle de
financement à l'échelon européen ce
financement passe par un consortium
d'électrointensif un prêt de l'opérateur
ou de l'État ou encore des fonds propres
en contrepartie d'un prix de long terme
fixe ou révisable s'agissant de la
France la cour des compte a indiqué que
le groupe ne pourrait assumer tout seul
ce financement quelle est votre
appréciation des choses enfin une
relance du nucléaire nécessite des
compétences la construction des 6 pr
c'est déjà 30000 emplois cert le groupe
et la filière ont réalisé un effort
considérable sur ce plan mais est à la
hauteur du défi l'État ne devrait-il pas
s'engager davantage à leur côté pour
atteindre les
objectifs ma 4è interrogation a trait
aux énergies renouvelables et au
vectcteur hydrogène le groupe EDF est
très engagé en faveur du déploiement de
l'énergie sol de l'éolien en mer de
l'hydrogène du stockage ou de
l'électromobilité les objectifs de 30 GW
du Plan solaire de 2017 de 10 GW du plan
stockage de 2018 et de 3 GW du plan
hydrogène de 2022 sont-ils encore
d'actualité ne faudrait-il pas les
rehausser au regard de l'ambition du
paquet ajustement 55 et pourquoi ne pas
fixer d'objectif en matière d'éoli en
mer dans notre rapport avec mes
collègues Jean-Pierre Moga et
Jean-Jacques Michot nous avons plaidé
pour développer l'hydrogène au côté du
nucléaire car la stratégie française en
la matière doit avant tout se fonder sur
un hydrogène issu du réseau
d'électricité partagez-vous cette
position pensez-vous que le projet de
loi d'accélération des énergies
nouvelables soit suffisant au regard des
besoins de la transition énergétique car
il est complètement muet sur
l'hydroélectricité et d'hydrogène et ma
dernière
questioniment concerne le marché
européen de l'électricité
étant donné que la crise énergétique
actuelle est aussi une crise européenne
d'une part les objectifs fixés par le
paquet ajustement à l'objectif 55 vous
semble-t-il réaliste dans ce cadre de
nos travaux avec ma collègue Dominique
estrosisason nous avons relever un
manque de neutralité technologique en en
énergie renouvelable et bas carbone et
entre hydrogène renouvelable et bas
carbone cela nous semble mettre en cause
le droit souverain des États à définir
leur mix énergétique partagez-vous cette
opinion d'autre part les mesures
proposées par le plan
r vous paraissent-elles suffisante la
révision du marché européen
d'électricité avec un découplage du prix
d'électricité et celui du gaz est
souvent évoqué comment l'imaginez-vous
voilà Monsieur Raymond les questions que
je souhaitais vous poser et je suis
impatient d'entendre vos réponses vous
avez 10
minutes monsieur RM à vous merci madame
la Présidente merci monsieur monsieur le
rapporteur je vais essayer de répondre
aux questions de Monsieur gréier dans
mon propos liminaire pas forcément
toutes mais je on pourra y revenir juste
après si vous le voulez bien d'abord je
voudrais dire madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
Messieurs les sénateur que que c'est
vraiment un honneur pour moi de me
présenter à vous
aujourd'hui devant votre commission à la
demande du Président de la République
qui vous a saisi du projet de me nommer
comme président directeur général de DF
si euh
le conseil d'administration de DF le
propose et si le Parlement l'approuve
bien sûr vous n'entendez pas pardon
alors je vais me rapprocher du micro
voilà alors par l'importance de sa
mission et grâce au succès qui ont
émaillé son histoire naturellement vous
m'entendez maintenant c'est bon
EF est une fierté nationale dont nos
concitoyens attendent légitimement
beaucoup les générations de femmes et
d'hommes qui ont façonné cette
entreprise depuis depuis 1946 peuvent
être fi de leur contribution au
développement de notre pays et c'est
convaincu du rôle essentiel et
stratégique que joue EDF et qu'il aura à
jouer dans les prochaines décennies et
de l'ampleur de la responsabilité de
diriger cette entreprise que je me
présente à vous aujourd'hui comme votre
votre commission va devoir se prononcer
sur ma capacité à assurer les fonctions
de président directeur général de DF il
me semble que je dois surmonter ma
rétiscence naturelle à parler de moi
pour vous dire d'abord deux choses l'une
générale l'autre plus
personnelle avant de vous décrire
brièvement mon parcours et d'essayer de
répondre en cela à une question du
rapporteur la première chose générale
c'est que je vois ce rôle moins comme
une fonction que comme une
mission l'énergie la transition
énergétique l'électricité son prix
aujourd'hui notamment le nucléaire les
énergies renouvelables les réseaux et
englobe à tout c tout cela l'avenir de
DF c'est évidemment un sujet qui
dans les temps que nous traversons
suppose la mobilisation de toutes les
énergies à commencé par la
mienne et donc je voudrais simplement
vous dire que j'y suis prêt et quand ça
j'ai le sentiment d'être
d'ailleurs totalement aligné et je suis
convaincu que tous les personnels de
l'entreprise sont également dans cet
état d'esprit de forte mobilisation le
son point qui est plus personnel est le
suivant si je suis prêt à assumer cette
mission que vous avez qualifié de
difficile madame la Présidente c'est
parce que j'y trouve l'occasion de por
à leur aboutissement des idéaux que je
porte depuis ma
jeunesse je crois avoir servi l'intérêt
général dans tous les postes que j'ai
occupé qui soit dans le secteur public
ou dans le secteur
privé mais EDF pour dire un peu
familièrement c'est autre
chose c'est peut-être la mission d'une
vie c'est pour un homme qui au moment de
ses études a rêvé d'être ingénieur au
moment des concours républicain a fait
de son mieux pour aller dans cette
direction dans le but de servir
l'industrie française et pour qui vient
le moment de rendre par cette mission à
son pays tout ce qu'il a pu donner à un
jeune français comme les autres élevé
dans les valeurs du mérite et du
travail alors pour vous dire un peu plus
sur mon parcours monsieur le rapporteur
je suis ingénieur de formation je n'ai
jamais cessé d'apprendre pendant bientôt
30 ans de vie
professionnelle qui ont été dédié pour
moitié au service de l'État pour moitié
à la vie d'entreprise dans les
différents métiers qui m'ont offert la
chance d'une expérience diversifiée mon
parcours a toujours été focalisé sur le
développement de l'industrie française
et avec une très large partie dédié au
monde de l'énergie dans mes années au
service de l'État j'ai appris le
développement d'une filière
technologique complexe dans les systèmes
spatiaux à la Direction générale de
l'armement puis au trésor celui des
grands projets d'infrastructure avec les
banques de
développement j'ai participé aux
négociations du protocole de Kyoto sur
le changement climatique j'ai suivi la
mise en sûreté des centrales nucléaires
du bloc de l'Est à la fin des années
90 je j'ai ensuite au début des années
2000 toujours au sein du ministère des
Finances j'ai soutenu le développement
la transformation des entreprises dont
l'état est actionnaire dans une période
d'évolution rapide notamment toutes les
entreprise du secteur public à la fois
pour leur régulation et pour leur
projets industriels j'y ai connu
naturellement de nombreuses négociations
communautaire à cette période et c'est
aussi à cette période que j'ai découvert
le secteur de l'énergie qui vivait l'une
de ses premières mutations à l'échelle
européenne il y en a bien sûr eu
beaucoup d'autres depuis j'ai souhaité
ensuite apprendre davantage en exerçant
une activité opérationnelle dans le
monde de l'entreprise j'ai commencé dans
le secteur financier au moment de la
crise financière j'ai apris la conduite
d'une activité en crise alors que le
monde financier s'écroulait l'importance
de rester proche de ses clients en
toutes
circonstances et j'ai continué de
développer ma connaissance de
l'industrie française et internationale
en en accompagnant le développement
stratégique et le financement de
nombreux groupes je reviendrai plus tard
si vous le permettez sur le groupe
Alstom monsieur le rapporteur enfin
depuis bientôt 9 ans c'est avec beaucoup
de bonheur que je sers le groupe
Schneider électrique un autre flleuron
de notre industrie française qui est un
leader technologique mondial engagé dans
la décarbonation de la planète grâce à
l'électrification de nos usages et à
l'utilisation de technologie Digital
pour améliorer l'efficacité énergétique
et opérationnelle de tout type
d'infrastructure je dirige depuis
bientôt 6 ans l'activité du groupe dans
une soixantaine de pays principalement
les pays émergents euh qui représente
environ un/4 du chiffre d'affaires du
groupe avec une présence opérationnelle
industrielle et humaine euh très forte
mon activité m'amène à diriger des
équipes pluridisciplinaires de cultures
extrêmement différentes euh et de
développer leurs compétences au service
de nos clients de notre technologie et
de notre capacité industrielle
m'a conduit à travailler Ave la plupart
des opérateurs électriques de ces pays
pour leur modernisation technique et
numérique et à connaître l'évolution de
marchés de l'électricité extrêmement
varié enfin pendant cette période à la
demande de l'État j'ai été pendant 5 ans
membre du conseil d'administration de
naval group me donnant l'occasion de
suivre de près comme président du comité
d'audit de ce groupe le seul programme
de série de chaufferie nucléaire à ce
jour en France qui est le programme des
sous-marins d'attaque Barracuda
euh c'est nourri de ces expériences
diversifiées et conscient qu'il me faut
encore beaucoup apprendre que j'aborde
cette nouvelle phase de ma vie
professionnelle au-delà des compétences
et de l'expérience accumulée je sais que
la réussite de la mission suppose
d'abord de mobiliser toute l'entreprise
et l'ensemble des parties prenant autour
d'un projet d'avenir pour l'électricité
dans lequel le DF jouera pleinement son
rôle j'y trouve une très grande
motivation et je voudrais partager avec
vous quelques idées initiales qui ne
sont que celles d'un observateur
extérieur à l'entreprise pour l'instant
et sur la façon dont je perçois la les
priorités stratégiques pour EDF tout
d'abord vous l'avez rappelé madame la
Présidente et monsieur le rapporteur
nous sommes dans un contexte critique à
court terme qui rappelle le rôle
essentiel joué par l'énergie et en
particulier par l'électricité dans nos
sociétés alors que l'Europe a bénéficié
d'une grande sécurité énergétique
pendant plusieurs décennies l'énergie
est devenue aujourd'hui une arme dont
use la Russie pour affléblir nos
sociétés et diviser l'Union européenne
donc avant même de parler de prix de
l'énergie c'est notre capacité à
disposer de suffisamment
d'énergie pour répondre à nos besoins
qui est en jeu avec l'arrêt
d'approvisionnement de l'Europe en gaz
russe notamment malheureusement dans ce
contexte de crise énergétique EDF
traverse elle-même une crise sérieuse
d'ordre technique et industriel qui
accentue la tension sur l'offre
d'énergie alors vous avez parler du
phénomène qui est inattendu he de
corrosion sur sous contrainte sur
certains réacteurs nucléaires qui est
venu soudainement aggraveré la tendance
baissière qu'on observait depuis certain
nombre d'années de la production
nucléaire lié au vieillissement du parc
et à la nécessité d'entretien je n'ai
pas à ce stade une connaissance
suffisante de ce phénomène pour livrer
un diagnostic mais ce que je constate
c'est que l'entreprise en liaison avec
l'Autorité de sûreté nucléaire a
appliqué d'emblé des mesures de de de
sûreté et en mettant la sûreté au
premier plan ce qui constitue un
essentiel un élément essentiel du pacte
de confiance qui unit EDF à la nation et
que
immédiatement l'entreprise en liaison
avec les entreprises de la filière et
l'Autorité de sûreté ont mis en œuvre un
plan qui permet de développer les
solutions adaptées dans les meilleur
délai pour permettre la reprise de
production en toute sûreté j'ai été
confronté moi-même plusieurs fois à des
difficultés de production soit au sein
de cheneder électrique soit chez nos
clients chîn électrique est un opérateur
qui fournit des solutions de de de de
procédés Industri et de sécurité dans
les procédés industriels donc ça nous
arrive aussi je sais que ça nécessite la
mobilisation de toute l'entreprise et de
l'ensemble du secteur je pense
qu'aujourd'hui cette mobilisation est
celle de DF et dès les premières heures
de mon mandat si vous me confirmez dans
cette direction je me consacrerai
totalement à la tête et au côté des
équipes de DF avec les entreprises de la
filière à tenir les engagements de
l'entreprise pour la reprise de la
production des réacteurs à
l'arrêt alors au-delà de la production
électrique nucléaire la situation de
tension énergétique liée au gaz euh et à
d'hydroélectricité qu'il faut pas
oublier parce que le la sécheresse de
l'été dans toute l'Europe a a des effets
sur la production électrique euh pour
pour cet hiver dans toute l'Europe euh
nous impose de nous préparer
collectivement au passage de l'hiver par
un effort de réduction de notre
consommation je suis convaincu de très
longuees dates euh de la nécessité de la
sobriété et de l'efficacité énergétique
je soutiens totalement les initiatives
permettant à chacun d'agir en citoyen et
cet effort collectif est indispensable
pour alléger la demande et diminuer les
risques de délestage cet hiver et les
suivants et donc nous continuerons de
d'y devraer en ce sens le prix de
l'électricité est bien sûr la résultante
de toutes ces tensions et sur le gaz le
nucléaire mais aussi l'y l'hydraulique à
l'échelle européenne à court terme les
clients français bénéficient d'une
meilleure protection que les voisins
européens
le prix de l'élericité en Europe est en
moyenne deux fois plus élevé qu'en
France aujourd'hui il existe pourtant
des des situations difficiles et
certains d'entre vous on en déjà parlé
et je j'en suis bien conscient je le
sais je n'en suis pas satisfait je
travaillerai avec les clients de DF et
avec le gouvernement pour trouver des
solutions adaptées chaque fois que c'est
possible dans ce contexte la situation
financière de DF se temp sous l'effet
conjugué de la baisse de la production
et des mesures de régulation
destiné à limiter les hausses de prix de
l'électricité cette situation nécessite
de la vigilance à court terme pour ne
pas devoir réduire les investissements
et compromettre l'avenir elle devrait
s'améliorer avec la reprise de la
production du parc nucléaire mais elle
nécessite impérativement de trouver un
équilibre et une visibilité de long
terme de la régulation permettant de
nous engager dans un nouveau cycle
d'investissement devenu
indispensable ceci me conduit maintenant
à aborder les perspectives de moyen
terme de DF en essayant de répondre à
certaines des autres autre question de
monsieur le rapporteur alors tous les
experts internationaux confirment le
rôle grandissant de l'électricité
décarboné dont toutes les formes devront
être mobilisé le nucléaire l'hydraulique
l'éolien le solaire le thermique
décarboné le stockage la flexibilité les
smart grid j'ai vu dans mes fonctions
actuelles à quel point ce mouvement est
mondial et à quel point la croissance
des besoins en électricité nécessite une
intelligence de système de la production
au clients en passant par les réseaux je
suis convaincu que nous sommes au début
d'une révolution industrielle fondée sur
l'électricité et le numérique et de
l'importance de l'électricité pour
atteindre l'ambition de la France d'être
neutre en carbone en 2050 de manière
générale EDF est attendu comme un acteur
absolument majeur dans cette transition
au fil des dernières années évidemment
EDF a connu une muue très importante du
grand service public de l'électricité
engagé dans la production électrique
dans les réseaux la commercialisation
d'un tarif unique il s'est transformé en
l'espace de deux décennies en un acteur
d'un marché européen concurrentiel
producteur d'électricité aussi bien
nucléaire que renouvelable développant
et construisant des installations de
production d'électricité décarboné en
France et en Europe et dans le monde son
offre commerciale s'est considérablement
diversifié pour satisfaire les attentes
du marché et les réseaux se sont adaptés
à la décentralisation et à la
numérisation c'est aujourd'hui un grand
énergéticien mondial et qui doit
continuer à tenir ce rang euh grâce à
l'étendue et à la qualité des
compétences dont elle dispose et par la
nature même de de sa raison d'être EDF
est bien placé pour jouer ce rôle de
premier plan dans ce nouveau monde
électrique et je voudrais détailler un
certain nombre de piliers stratégique
qui me paraiss essentielle pour la
succès le succès de la mission de DF
j'ai observé beaucoup d'opérateurs
électriques dans le monde et je crois
que le succès de leur mission repose sur
la capacité de développer de façon
optimale trois piliers d'activité
qui constitue un système
d'ensemble comme pour toute industrie
les solutions permettant aux clients
d'optimiser leur consommation
énergétique d'une part une production
compétitive et résiliente de diverses
sources d'électricité d'autre part et
enfin des réseaux permettant d'assurer
la fourniture et l'équilibre partout et
à tout moment dans le respect bien sûr
de leur gouvernance spécifique je
commencerai par les clients sans qui
aucune entreprise n'existe encore plus
pour EDF dont le rôle est premier dans
la satisfaction des besoins collectifs
les difficultés de court terme sur les
prix de l'électricité doivent conduire à
accélérer les solutions permettant aux
clients entreprises particulierers
collectivités de mieux gérer leur
énergie il y a d'ors et déjà une
accélération massive en France des
raccordements d'autoconsommation qui est
un rattrapage par rapport à d'autres
pays EDF doit continuer à accompagner
ses clients dans leur transition
énergétique cela concerne les
entreprises et les collectivités dans
leurs installations industrielles ou
tertièes ou pour développer des outils
intelligents pour les aider à piloter
leur consommation cela concerne
également les particuliers qui
souhaitent réduire leur consommation
électrifier leur véhicules installer une
pompe à chaleur ou devenir
autoconsommateur ces évolutions ainsi
que le développement de la capacité de
stockage permettront d'introduire
davantage de flexibilité dans le système
électrique qui en a grandement besoin et
d'accompagner l'électrification des
usages en limitant les volumes
d'investissements en moyen de production
centralisé la priorité d'ODF est donc
d'apporter toutes ces solutions
innovantes à l'ensemble de ses clients
je voudrais maintenant aborder les
enjeux de la production électrique nous
sommes à la croisée des chemins comme
les analyses de très grande qualité
publiées par RTE sur les différents
scénarios de production et
d'investissement d'ici
2050 l'ont montré avec une perspective
très éclairante sur
l'avenir sans entrer dans le détail de
du commentaire de chaque scénario
puisquil y a il y a beaucoup de
scénarios qui montrent un éventail de de
de situations
possibles il me pas raisonnable de dire
que le problème qui se pose à nous
aujourd'hui est moins de piloter
finement la part de chaque mode de
production que de nous mettre en mesure
collectivement de produire suffisamment
de chacun de ces modes pour assurer une
production une production suffisante et
diversifiée à terme donc je je vais
passer en revue ces différents modes en
commençant par le nucléaire et et
simplement partager avec vous ma vision
de la façon dont on peut évoluer sur
chacun de ces modes alors il est clair
qu'il y a pas de stratégie bas carbone
possible sans production
nucléaire c'est évidemment une approche
de la France depuis très longtemps ce
qui est intéressant c'est que de plus en
plus de pays parviennent à cette
conclusion et je l'ai constaté dans mes
fonctions
d'aujourd'hui tout simplement parce que
le nucléaire est la seule énergie seule
source de production électrique
aujourd'hui fournissant une électricité
de base non carboné nous avons la chance
que nos anciens a réussi une performance
inouï qui est de dével
une filière industrielle et de déployer
58 réacteurs en moins de 20 ans qui nous
permett de bénéficier aujourd'hui d'une
d'une électricité compétitive et
abondante
entretenir et prolonger la durée vie de
ce parc est naturellement la première
priorité d'investissement de DF avec le
programme du grand carénage mais il nous
faut également être prêt pour le moment
où la performance de nos anciens nous
rattrapera sous forme d'un effet falaise
lorsqu'on ne pourra plus prolonger ce
parc euh et où il nous faudra trouver
une source de renouvellement euh c'est
la raison pour laquelle le le nouveau
programme nucléaire français doit
maintenant être rapidement lancé pour
que nous disposions durablement d'une
électricité de base suffisante et c'est
le cap fixé par le président de la
République dans son discours de
bellefor alors c'est d'abord un défi
humain euh c'est bien comme ça que je le
prends je suis convaincu que disposer
des compétences les plus pointues dans
l'ensemble de la filière nucléaire est
cruciale pour parvenir à relever le
niveau de production et pour sécuriser
aussi le grand programme industriel qui
s'annonce avec la construction des
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires j'ai
conscience du rôle singulier de DF à la
tête de la filière nucléaire qu'elle
recompose activement avec l'intégration
de Framatome en 2018 bientôt sans doute
avec celle des activités nucléaires de
generaléral électrique il nous faudra
structurer amplifier le travail mené
depuis quelques années pour attirer les
talents dans ces métiers euh à tiré d'à
nouveau à nouveau vers l'industrie en
France et j'aurais à cœur de garantir la
filière dispose durablement des
compétences nécessaires pour relever le
grand défi qui se présente à elle
naturellement il y a de nombreuses
autres dimensions nous pourrons y
revenir technique financière
industrielle à ce défi ce n'est pas
seulement celui de l'entreprise mais
celui de la nation euh et je
m'attacherai à définir avec les pouvoirs
publics l'ensemble des modalités
nécessaires au succès de ce programme
avec l'obsession de fournir aux Français
une électricité abondante sûre
compétitive et durable dans les
meilleurs délais je voudrais passer
maintenant à l'hydraulique et au
renouvelablebles si vous le voulez bien
euh nous devrons aussi trouver un chemin
de développement pour l'hydraulique euh
l'eau est une ressource dont les usages
sont multiples euh absolument majeurs
que soit pour l'énergie l'agriculture le
tourisme et nous devons exploiter tout
son potentiel le rôle de DF auprès des
collectivités est d'assurer la cohérence
de la ressource tout au long des cours
d'eau et de conjuguer une production
hydrolectrique durable et les autres
usages tout en préservant la
biodiversité les projets
d'investissement ne se réalis pas
aujourd'hui par manque de visibilité sur
le cadre de long terme donc je je sais
que les discussions sont en cours
monsieur le rapporteur vous les avez
mentionné
sur sur comment fournir un tel cadre à
EDF et je m'attacherai à ce qu'elles
aboutissent pour permettre de relancer
ce secteur le développement des
renouvelables je sais qu'il vous occupe
beaucoup y compris la nuit en ce moment
est également une composante essentielle
d'une production diversifiée pour EDF en
tant qu'opérateur de système électrique
EDF si largement engagé avec des
partenaires financiers permettant de
partager les besoins
d'investissement la France n'est pas en
reste dans le développement de DF dans
les EnR puisque le groupe est leader de
l'éolien terrestre il est leader de
l'éolien maritime en France et dans le
podium sur le solaire mais nous savons
qu'il faut accélérer EDF ne sera
naturellement performant en France que
en restant un acteur mondial dont la
taille critique permet de bénéficier
d'effet d'échelle d'avoir des conditions
d'achat optimales en partageant
naturellement avec des partenaires les
investissements nécessaires pour ne pas
peser excessivement sur la capacité de
financement du
groupe le troisième pilier indispensable
du système électrique est la performance
des réseaux les réseaux de transport et
distributions sont eux-mêmes en pleine
mutation pour faciliter la transition
énergétique et l'importance de
l'électricité dans notre quotidien amène
logiquement à une très grande exigence
de qualité le métier de la distribution
électrique est très fortement ancré dans
le territoire et accompagne les
changements profonds associés à la
production renouvelable
décentralisée la flexibilité accrue de
l'offre et la demande d'électricité
locale change profondément la nature du
métier de gestionnaire de réseau et
nécessite des investissements importants
en raccordant en raccordement et en
système numérique et ça je l'ai vu dans
le monde entier nous passons d'un
système unidirectionnel qui permettait
l'acheminement de l'électricité depuis
de grands centres de production vers les
consommateurs ainsi système
bidirectionnel qui maille le territoire
en permettant la flexibilité et
l'échange d'électricité c'est une c'est
une évolution c'est même une révolution
qui se passe dans tous les pays du monde
et la priorité pour EDF dans le respect
de la gouvernance spécifique des réseau
bien sûr et de soutenir ces
transformations dans un cadre de
régulation
adapté je voudrais ajouter un point
simple mais essentiel répondant à cela
en partie je pense à monsieur le
rapporteur aussi qui est que pour
répondre à tous ces en je stratégique du
système électrique ce ne sera possible
que si nous réformons profondément les
règles de marché à l'échelle européenne
bien sûr et en partie à l'échelle
nationale pour permettre
l'investissement et donner à EDF un
cadre de moyen terme stable la crise
énergétique actuelle vous l'avez
souligné madame la Présidente met en
lumière un certain nombre de faiblesses
de nos règles de marché européens les
gouvernements européen on adapté des
mesures d'urgence pour faire face aux
défis les plus immédiats et protéger les
consommateurs des hausses ex habitante
de prix de gros en agissant sur le gaz
électrogène et sur les prix de
production d'électricité mais au-delà de
la crise actuelle il est indispensable
de réfléchir au futur cadre de marché
européen pour compenser les
défaillances des règles de marché mises
en lumière par la crise actuelle euh le
premier je je vous livre quelques idées
qui sont des idées préliminaires et sur
lesquelles il faudra naturellement que
je travaille beaucoup et et pas tout
seul avec l'ensemble des acteurs du
secteur euh le premier élément c'est que
nous avons un cadre de marché qui est
trop exclusivement focalisé sur le court
terme et sur l'équilibre de court terme
la deuxième défaillance est que il y a
naturellement une conséquence lourde de
la formation du prix de l'électricité à
partir du prix du gaz alors que
l'évolution du mix de production fait
que le prix du gaz représente une côte
part de enfin le gaz représente une côte
part de plus en plus faible de la
production électricité et que nous avons
de plus en plus de production à coûpt
variable
nul le troisème élément c'est qu'il y a
une une insuffisante prise en compte des
besoins de flexibilité dans le
fonctionnement du marché notamment sous
forme de contrat de long terme et de
pilotage de la demande voilà les
éléments qui pour quelqu'un qui a opéré
dans beaucoup d'autres marchés
électriques revient vers le marché
européen frappe et donc sur lesquels je
compte travailler je suis heureux de
voir que le sommet européen de la
semaine dernière a permis d'engager le
travail communautaire pour repenser le
cadre de marché et évidemment EDF
apportera ses idées et son expertise aux
autorités françaises et européennes à
qui il revient de fixer le cadre de
marché dans le cas plus spécifique de DF
le mécanisme de l'AREN est à bout de
souffle euh s'il a permis de protéger
les clients de prix de marché trop
élevés y compris en ce moment il n'a pas
permis de développer de véritables
investissements concurrents tout en
affaiblissement tout en affaiblissant
sérieusement ce de DF donc son échéance
est fixé à 2025 et je m'attacherai à
créer avec l'État et la Commission
européenne l'indispensable visibilité à
moyen un terme nécessaire pour sécuriser
la trajectoire d'investissement de deff
pour le pays je terminerai ce volet
stratégique d'un mot sur la préparation
de l'avenir parce que je pourrais être
beaucoup plus long et je le serai trop
comme ingénieur je suis convaincu que
l'évolution technologique va continuer
de nous apporter des solutions nouvelles
pour l'électricité c'est le rôle de DF
dans le domaine de la Red recherche et
développement d'y
contribuer et c'est aussi la raison de
la présence à l'international qui est
destiné à connaître et à pratiquer des
environnement électrique
différents sur tous ces aspects
stratégiques qui s'inscrivent dans la
continuité de la raison d'être de DF
défin sous l'égy de Jean-Bernard leville
avec une très large participation de
l'ensemble de l'entreprise j'engagerai
un travail en profondeur avec les équipe
de DF dans les premiers mois destinés à
proposer une feuille de route d'ici le
printemps au moment de conclure je
voudrais partager avec vous quelques
convictions fortes qui guide mon action
en tant que dirigeant
d'entreprise je crois que la
satisfaction des est le premier objectif
de toute entreprise je crois que la
réussite de l'entreprise n'est possible
que par l'engagement et le développement
des compétences et des talents des
personnes qui la composent que la
diversité des origines et des savoirs et
la mixité sont indispensables à la
réussite d'une équipe que le dialogue
entre les parties prenantes de
l'entreprise et le dialogue social crée
la confiance nécessaire au progrès que
la concurrence et la compétition sont
bénéfiques à l'entreprise en la poussant
à faire mieux sans cesse que
la culture de l'engagement et de la
performance est indispensable en la
poussant à la réchite d'un projet
d'entreprise que la responsabilité
sociale d'entreprise est un engagement
et pas une
contrainte qu'il est possible de
concilier la préservation de la planète
le développement et le bien-être et que
l'électricité décarbonée est un atout
majeur de progrès et d'industrialisation
alorsedf n'est certes pas une entreprise
comme les autres dépositaire du modèle
du service public animé par l'intérêt
général l'entreprise doit relever en
même temps de nombreux défis au-delà des
défis du moment je crois qu'elle est en
mesure de renouer avec l'excellence et
l'exemplarité industrielle qui fait
notre fierté partout dans le monde et de
jouer un rôle majeur dans l'avenir
électrique l'actionnariat de DF est
appelé à évoluer dans le cadre du projet
de l'état de détenir 100
% du capital en tant qu'actionnaire de
long terme en plein accord avec l'État
actionnaire je veux dire ici que les EDF
restera géré comme une entreprise
industrielle avec son intérêt social et
sa personnalité morale propre euh et ce
sera naturellement ma mission et ma
façon de
travailler je souhaite aborder cette
mission en bâtissant une vision d'avenir
une relation confiante avec les pouvoirs
publics indispensable pour réussir à
relever les défis d'ampleur national qui
sont devant nous EDF ne peut réussir à
servir le pays qu'avec cette relation de
confiance je m'attacherai à ce qu'elle
soit nourrie de contact régulier avec
votre commission et avec l'ensemble des
élus dans les territoires et je serais
naturellement heureux de revenir devant
vous si naturellement vous confirmez ma
nomination dans quelques mois si vous le
permettez voilà madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je vous remercie
de votre attention je suis naturellement
à votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions en vous remerciant de bien
vouloir m'excuser si mes réponses à ce
stade qui sont celles d'un observateur
extérieur peuvent manquer un peu de
précision et peut-être si vous me le
permettez madame la Présidente puis-je
commencer par essayer de répondre à
celles des questions de Monsieur le
rapporteur que je n'aurais pas d'ors et
déjà couvert dans euh dans mon propos
liminaire
euhstom Alstom alorsors Alstom donc com
comme dans tout sujet industriel il faut
un peu de perspective parce que les les
faits industriels sont sur le long terme
je je rappelle qu'Alstom a a acquis au
tout début des années 2000 l'activité de
production électrique de turbine à gaz
notamment euh d'un groupe suéo euh
Suisse qui s'appelle ABB
et que cette acquisition a amené Alstom
tout au bord de la faillite à l'été 2003
puisque les turbin en question n'était
pas de qualité et donc avait conduit
l'ensemble des clients de ces turbines à
réclamer à Alstom 4 milliards
d'euros à l'époque le ministre des
Finances que j'avais l'honneur de servir
à qui je veux rendre hommage ici qui
était Francis ma apris une décision
courageuse qui est dire nous ne
laisserons pas Alstom partir à la
faillite et nous
nous mettrons en place un plan qui
permet de péréniser l'ensemble des
activités d'Alstom et Alstom a continué
son chemin traversant cette crise très
difficile et et se redrant et donc cette
activité de production électrique de
turbines qui était des turbines à gaz à
vapeur et cetera et cetera a poursuivi
son chemin sur une décennies traversant
d'autres défis donc les défis qui ont
suivi ont été naturellement la crise
financière et puis l'accélération de la
transition énergétique dans le monde
entier si bien que au début de la
décennie 2010 euh le monde de des
turbines à gaz notamment le monde des
fabricants de turbines à gaz était en
crise mondiale parce que plus aucune
nouvelle turbine à gaz n'était fabriqué
où que ce soit et ce métier ne vivait
plus que de la maintenance de la base
installée des turbines à gaz et Alstom
qui était convalescent dans ce mondelà
les leaders mondiaux étant g Electric
Siemens et Mitsubishi s'est retrouvver
dans la situation dans laquelle ce
métier allait souffrait énormément et
risquait à nouveau d'emmener l'ensemble
du groupe dans des difficultés et donc
les dirigeants d'Alstom de l'époque ont
naturellement cherché les évolutions
stratégiques indispensables pour
préserver cette activité d'une part mais
également préserver la compétitivité de
l'ensemble du groupe et c'est dans ce
cadre que en tant que banquier
d'affaires je m'en excuse c'est un
métier j'ai été j'ai été amené à
participer simplement à la prise de
contact initiale avec général électrique
qui est un grand industriel
euh partenaire de safran depuis 50 ans
ayant permis à safran de devenir avec
génér électrique ensemble leader mondial
d'un des segments du plus large segment
des moteurs aéronautiques donc c'est
aussi un grand partenaire de
d'industriel français donc voilà j'ai
participé à ce premier contact et
ensuite suite j'étais parti chez
schnedrique donc je n'ai pas suivi le
reste de cette de cette
transformation très bien merci beaucoup
je je vais activer le processus de
question vous êtes extrêmement nombreuse
qui montre l'intérêt que notre
commission porte évidemment à EDF et à
votre nomination je demanderai donc à
nos collègues de poser vite leurs
questions vraiment 1 minute 30 maximum
parce que nous devons laisser Monsieur
Raymond à 10h30 vous êtes aujourd'hui 15
à poser des questions pour aller à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est pas une
fantaisie de sa part c'est juste une
obligation voilà on va commencer par
Jean-Claude tissau ensuite Jean-Pierre
Moga merci madame la Présidente je vais
être très bref monsieur rmon bonjour
j'ai une seule question pour que nous
ayons une vision précise de votre
orientation et de vos objectifs pour
EDF après avoir suivi la privatisation
des autoroutes et de la Société
Nationale maritime Corse Méditerranée
après avoir participé à la
libéralisation du marché de l'énergie et
de la privatisation de GDF après avoir
travaillé pour la l'introduction en
bourse de DF lors de vos passages dans
les cabinets ministériels de Bery après
avoir supervisé la vente d'Alstom à
général électrique lors de votre passage
dans une banque d'investissement comment
l'expert de la privatisation et de la
libéralisation que vous êtes compteagir
pour participer à la renationalisation
d'ODF n'est-ce pas un aveu que le projet
Hercule est de retour avec une
privatisation à venir des actifs
intéressants et une simple
nationalisation de la production
nucléaire merci merci Jean-Claude
Jean-Pierre Moget ensuite Fabien Guay
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
Raymond d'ors et déjà j'avais plusieurs
questions mais vous avez répondu à
certaines don je ne vous les reposerai
pas notamment il y en avait une sur la
reine je voulais vous interroger moi sur
les SMR ces petites ces petits réacteurs
modulaires qu'on peut fabriquer en en
série exporter ou utiliser sur le
territoire national à m et cetera à des
endroits où on n' pas de la la
possibilité aujourd'hui en dehors des
énergies fossiles de de produire de de
l'électricité donc je voulais savoir la
stratégie que vous envisagez de porter
au au sein du groupe
EDF pour pour fabriquer développer et
commercialiser euh ce type de de peties
centrale sachant que vous y avez fait
allusion vous avez été chez naval groupe
on a quand même au niveau national une
expérience avec les chaufferies des
sous-marins et de et de notre porteavion
voilà je vous remercie merci pardon de
vous de vous pré Fabien Guay ensuite
Martine Bert merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur Rimon je suis un grand
défenseur de DF et et ses usagers deux
questions moi j'ai pas bien compris ce
que vous pensiez sur l'arine moi qui a
un système de spoliation de DF et de ses
usagers faut-il en finir avant 2027 et
quelle régulation vous proposez après et
la deuxième chose moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est votre feuille de route on est
privé de débat parlementairire on a une
réétatisation de DF sans débat qui va
rester une société anonyme et donc c'est
quoi votre feuille de route est-ce que
c'est reprendre un hercu 2.0 avec une
filialisation une vente d'actif vous
allez avoir en tête une grande
entreprise avec 70 milliards de dett
est-ce que vous allez vendre des actifs
comme Dala est-ce que c'est se séparer
d'un certain nombre d'activités ou de
salariés où est-ce que vous venez pour
créer ou recréer un grand service public
de l'énergie je vous remercie merci
beaucoup Fabien Martine Bertet ensuite
Bernard bu merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur Raymond quelles actions
comptez-vous pensez-vous pouvoir
entreprendre avec 100 % du capital par
rapport au 84 % précédent quelles
actions supplémentaire et alors la
question est un peu liée au niveau des
concessions des barrages comment
que pensez-vous qu'il va se passer merci
merci beaucoup Martine Bernard bu
ensuite Vivian Artigalas merci
présidente deux questions rapidement
monsieur Raymon vous avez travaillé sur
l'introduction en Bourse d'df en 2005
aujourd'hui EDF fa l'objet d'une
renationalisation avec quel état
d'esprit comptez-vous aborder cette
nouvelle étape dans la vie d'EDF si
votre candidature est retenue ma deuxème
question porte sur la relance de
l'énergie nucléaire quelles seront vos
priorités la relance du parc nucléaire
est aujourd'hui retardé en raison d'une
pénurie de maindœuvre qualifié oredf
s'est engagé à redémarrer tous les
réacteurs à l'arrêt pour cet hiver comme
l'a souligné la ministre agè
panierunchier en septembre dernier cette
promesse est-elle tenable quelle mesure
comptez-vous prendre pour réussir
réussir ce défi et puis sénateur dromoi
je vous glisse bien sûr que le
territoire de pierreelat Ben Saint-Paul
3 château verrait d'un bon œil l' danse
de la construction du 3è pr
prochainement tout est
prêt
galas ensuite Amel gaker Viviane est là
oui merci donc les questions été posées
c'est sur les concessions
hydroélectrique mais je vais compléter
celle de Martine Berté en demandant vous
aussi est-ce que vous avez une feuille
de route si les concessions restent là
sur de nouveaux développement sur des
investissements à faire est-ce que vous
avez des objectifs à ce
sujetoup Vivian Amel gaker madame la
Présidente Monsieur Raymond cela a été
dit les enjeux du groupe F sont nombreux
et ce dans un contexte budgétaire plus
que tendu pour EDF notamment un enjeu
d'indépendance énergétique également une
énergie accessible à tous à un prix
acceptable vous avez déjà apporté pas
mal de réponses par contre deux sujets
n'ont pas encore été évoqués précisément
l'impact du coût de l'indépendance
énergétique sur les ménages français il
va falloir leur expliquer que
l'électricité va coûter de plus en plus
cher c'est un fait comment comptez-vous
engager cette évolution dans un contexte
de baisse généralisée du pouvoir d'
achat à plusieurs reprises ont été
évoqué également euh
les investissements nécessaires pour
renouveler optimiser le parc nucléaire
notamment les 6pr de seconde génération
annoncé par le président par contre n'a
pas encore été évoqué le sujet sensible
des déchet à longue durée de vie une
question essentielle pour les pays
équipés de réacteurs nucléaires qui
arriveront nécessairement en fin de vie
pour notre parc nucléaire français
vieillissant et défectueux fonctionnant
à 50 % donc quelle est votre vie sur ce
point sensible pour nos concitoyens pour
tous merci merci beaucoup
Amel Françoise ferra pardon excuse-moi
Françoise qui est là ensuite Laurent
Duplomb et je je dis à mes collègues que
je vous prends dans l'ordre de la boucle
WhatsApp voilà donc Françoise merci
madame la Présidente une question que je
pense particulière monsieur rmond si mes
informations sont justes une
concertation organisée par le
gouvernement a été é lancé pour
permettre au grand public de s'exprimer
sur l'avenir du bouquet énergétique
français avec évidemment le nucléaire au
cœur des débats trois grandes questions
seront posées avec comme objectif la
neutralité carbone en
2050 première question comment adapter
notre consommation comment satisfaire
nos besoins énergétiques tout en sortant
de notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles et comment planifier et
financer notre transition énergétique
alors évidemment je suis euh attaché à
la concertation mais monsieur riment je
m'interroge sur la méthode qui pourrait
vous permettre la prise en compte du
résultat des réponses du public et
avez-vous déjà élaboré cette
méthode merci beaucoup Françoise Laurent
dupl ensuite Franck
Ménonville merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur raaymond dans la vie il y a des
éléments extrinsecs et des éléments
intrinsèque dans les éléments
extrinsèques j'avais plutôt envie de ne
pas voter pour votre
accession à la présidence de DF mon avis
a plutôt évolué au vu de ce que vous
faites et du moins de ce que vous dites
puisque vous répondez directement aux
question et vous êtes pas venu avec une
batterie de conseil qui vous
expliquerait ce qu'il faudrait que vous
disiez de façon à ne pas prendre de
risque ou quoi que ce soit et je trouve
que c'est un point positif qui va
réviser ma
position dans les
éléments dans les éléments dans les
intrinsèque oui parce que tout
simplement je pense qu'à un moment donné
on crève de cette technocratie
abrutissante qui nous fait dire des
messages qui ne correspondent pas à la
réalité qui nous font prendre autre
chose que les bonnes décision Laurent tu
as le même temps que tout le monde donc
s'il te plaît rapidement dans les
éléments intrinsèques dans les éléments
intrinsèques dernièrement j'ai un
exemple sur mon département où un jeune
reprend une Syrie dépche-toi 8000 € de
de de charge d'électricité avant de le
reprendre une fois qu'il l'a repris
refait son contrat avec EDF on lui
annonce 69000 € la réponse qu'on lui don
donne s'il va avoir un tarif
préférentiel c'est de Siller de 9h du
soir à 5h du matin est-ce que là-dessus
vous allez pouvoir modifier ces réponses
qui sont complètement débile et qui
consiste à ne pas répondre à ceux qui se
posent des questions et des questions
vitales sur l'avenir de leur entreprise
merci beaucoup Franck Ménonville ensuite
Florence blatrix merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur Raymon une une
question
rapide vous avez
évoqué le président de la République a
évoqué le le renouvellement du nucléaire
l'ouverture d'un nouveau programme vous
le vous souhaitez bien évidemment le le
porter ma question elle est très clair
comment vous imaginez-vous son
déploiement sur sur le territoire se
fera-t-il en périphérie ou proche des
des installation existante allez-vous
réouvrir des des chantiers de
concertation territorial pour la pour
l'implantation de ces notamment de ces
et puis pour renvoyer à deux questions
de mes collègues je suis avec Gérard
Longuet mes deux collègues de hautmar
les sénateurs de du département
d'accueil du projet CGO donc je j'aurais
souhaité aussi vous entendre sur le le
sujet et puis la complémentarité
territoriale pr et SMR
voilà Franck Florence blastrixcta qui
est là-bas et ensuite Serge merillou
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
Raymond je souhaiterais vous interroger
sur la stratégie de opération
internationale et européenne de DF le
savoir-faire de DF vous l'avez dit et de
ces différentes entités et largement
reconnu ça me conduit tout d'abord à
vous interroger sur le grand chantier
d'inkleen point oou en est-il c'est un
chantier stratégique pour la France et
le Royaume-Uni mais il pèsera lourdement
dans vos comptes par ailleurs c'est
investissement réalisé avec le concours
de la compagnie chinoise CGN qui est un
partenaire de de longue date de DF
notamment pour les réacteurs pr conduits
à Taishan comment envisagez-vous la
poursuite de cette coopération
industrielle alors même que cette
entreprise est parfois concurrent pour
EDF et enfin peut-être une question
aussi sur le le la relation la
coopération avec l'Allemagne hein le
couple franco-allemand a toujours été
important dans notre politique
énergétique pendant longtemps très lié
ces deux pays ont semblaiit avoir des
politiques énergétiques divergente après
le retrait de
Siemens de du nucléaire quand
l'Allemagne a décidé de se retirer
quelles sont aujourd'hui les axes de
coopération franco-allemande dans votre
secteur que ce soit pour l'électricité
le nucléaire le
renouvelable et quelles sont les
coopérations envisagées avec les
industriels allemands je vous remercie
oui la question reprend pour l'Essen
l'intervention de Jean-Claude tissau
vous vous en doutez mais Daniel gréiller
au début de son son intervention
rappeler que l'enjeu était de cette
nomination était d'abord de donner un
cap à EDF qui entre nous en manque
cruellement mais quel cap allez-vous
donner parce que la question pour moi
c'est celle-là est-ce que vous allez
vous inscrire dans la poursuite de cette
dérive
ultralibérale de cette belle maison dont
vous dites qu'elle a fait parce que je
pense qu'aujourd'hui elle a fait la
fierté des femmes et des hommes qui
l'ont façonné et qui nous a amené dans
une situation dans lequelle nous nous
trouvons aujourd'hui où serez-vous euh
mandaté pour faire de cette très belle
maison l'outil stratégique au cœur de la
reconquête de notre souveraineté
énergétique parce que pouvant se
positionner sur des enjeux à moyen et
long
terme et puis c'est vrai que votre passé
de dirigeant d'entre
très libérale la politique libérale ne
PLA
pas en faveur
voilà merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur rmon je n'ai pas
compris sur quel mandat du gouvernement
repose la candidature que que vous
briguez quel est votre projet en réalité
organisationnel notamment est-ce qu'on
reste dans un groupe complètement
intégré est-ce que le EDF pour le
nouveau nucléaire fait l'objet d'une
filialisation particulière quelle est
votre position votre appréciation du du
du du projet Hercule et granddf qui a
qui a suivi voilà comment vous situer
par rapport à ça en matière économique
et financière je voudrais savoir quelle
mesure vous envisagez pour redresser la
trajectoire financière et bilancielle de
l'entreprise qui est très très
préoccupante euh vous avez avz parlé de
laarine vous avez dit ce que vous en
pensez dans l'hypothèse dans l'hypothèse
qui qui n'est pas certaine mais qui est
possible euh où la reine ne serait pas
supprimée qu'est-ce que vous faites et
en matière en matière tarifaire euh
est-ce que votre idée est de faire
d'aller vers des tarifs euh prenant en
compte les coûts de production complets
à long terme du mix énergétique national
euh en matière de de gouvernance à un
moment donné il a été question de
gouvernance duale de DF avec un
président et un directeur général
comment vous vous situez par rapport à
ça est-on appelé à se prononcer pour un
poste une fonction de PDG ou de
président qui serait doté par la suite
d'une fonction de directeur général ou
ou le contraire voilà et en matière de
financement du nouveau nucléaire dernier
point il est
important comment le financez-vous dans
le contexte actuel est-ce que vous
passez par exemple par des sociétés de
projets euh spécifiques de financement
spécifiqu qui remettrai évidemment en
cause l'intégrité euh ou
l'intégrité l'intégration du groupe tel
qu'on le connaît aujourd'hui je vous
remercie merci beaucoup Franck Dominique
Estrosi Sasson qui se trouve ici et
ensuite Daniel salmon merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur Raymond deux
questions très courtes le gouvernement a
levé l'interdiction de publicité pour
les offres vendues au tarif réglementé
comme l'offre Timpôt d'EDF euh jusqu'à
quand cette mesure exceptionnelle
est-elle en vigueur et combien enfin
quelles sont vos projections de
souscription euh d'abonnés dans les
prochains mois et la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie a lancé une
enquête sur des fraudes à l'arène de
certains fournisseurs qui gonflent leur
portefeuille clients pour bénéficier de
plus larges quotas d'électricité
nucléaire à prix cassé comment le groupe
EDF
entend-il faire valoir ses droits devant
la
justice merci beaucoup Dominique Daniel
salmon qui se trouve là-bas et ensuite
Joë Labé on fait un grouperé merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur Raymond le
le groupe EDF est très largement endetté
60 70 milliards la reine est souvent
montrée du Doig ma question concerne le
prix de du nucléaire historique à
combien évaluez-vous le
mgaw réel et non pas fictif du mgawh de
du nucléaire historique la filière
nucléaire vous le savez à de nombreux
maillons faibles euh en particulier on
peut parler en ce moment de des piscines
qui sont remplies àabord pouvez-vous
nous faire un point sur ce sur ce
maillon très
important votre équivalent
italien investit prévoit d'investir euh
dans une giga usine de panneaux
photovoltaïques que est-ce que EDF
compte emboîter le pas de Nel et dans ce
cas comment compte-il intégrer notre
petite filière photovoltaïque qui se
Meur celle de celle de
photowat je vous
remercie merci beaucoup Daniel Joë Labbé
et ensuite Anne-Catherine Loisier merci
madame la Présidente deux questions
rapides vous n'avez pas évoqué la
production d'énergie à partir
d'hydrogène
elle semble pourtant une filière
d'avenir dans la mesure où elle est
produite à partir de d'énergie
renouvelable je souhaiteraiis votre
point de vue là-dessus et les moyens à
mettre dans la recherche parce que cette
recherche n'est pas encore aboutie
seconde question vous avez beaucoup
parlé de production d'énergie c'est
votre cœur de métier mais je ne vous ai
pas entendu parler ou nous ne vous avons
pas entendu parler de sobriété
énergétique vous vendez de l'énergie
donc votre rôle c'est de vendre et la
sobriété fait en sorte que vous vous
vendiez le moins possible euh ce qui
fait ma conclusion j'aurais aimé vous
entendre parler plutôt d'usager que de
clien je vous
remercie très bien Anne-Catherine
Loisier ensuite Eveline Renaud garab
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
merci beaucoup pour cette présentation
en fait je dirais que vous avez partagé
des constats sur lesquels je pense qu'on
se retrouve tous mais on reste un petit
peu sur notre fin sur la stratégie
effectivement à venir voilà une fois
qu'on a fait ses constats comment ne pas
retomber
dans les écueils et voilà dans les
difficultés qu'on a pu constater et les
choix qui nous ont amené là où nous en
sommes aujourd'hui juste deux petites
question pratique vous n'avez pas je
crois parlé en fait de la problématique
de main d'œuvre qualifié donc comment
allez-vous répondre à ce défi majeur et
par contre vous avez évoqué le le
numérique électricité numérique le
pilotage numérique je pense qu'on est
tous d'accord sur l'intérêt de l'outil
par contre quand on dit numérique
aujourd'hui surtout dans un domaine
stratégique énergétique on dit dit aussi
vulnérabilité on le voit dans le
contexte de la guerre d'Ukraine avec les
émissions de de la Russie sur certain
nombre de dispositifs donc voilà comment
comptez-vous parer ces risques
majeurs merci beaucoup Anne-Catherine
Eveline Renault garabéan qui est tout au
fond à droite merci Monsieur Raymond
deux questions je souhaitais vous
interroger sur les cyberattaques que
peut subir ou subi F dans les semaines à
venir comme l'a dit ma collègue le
contexte des tensions qui existe sur le
secteur de l'énergie et de la crise
géopolitique avec la Russie pourrait
offrir de nouvelles opportunités aux
attaquants qu'il soit étatique ou
criminel que ce soit pour la pas du gain
ou bien pour des résolion d'objectifs
stratégiques comment est-ce que est-ce
que vous envisagez d'importer la
connaissance que vous aviez dans votre
ancienne activité chez Schneider
électrique et une 2uxè question la
semaine dernière nous avons
auditionné la la ministre de la
transition
énergétique avec laquelle nous avons
discuté sur la géothermie elle m nous a
indiqué qu'elle envisageait de
développer considérablement ce secteur
sous-exploité je voulais savoir ce que
vous envisagez par la suite de faire
avec la filiard d'alica notamment avec
les 50 installations germie existant en
France Merci Merci beaucoup evveline
Micheline Jacques qui est caché où merci
présidente voilà à droite dans les
territoires ultramarins où l'énergie
solaire est prédominante le gouvernement
a décidé de revoir à la baisse le coût
de rachat de l'énergie injectée dans le
réseau occasionn un ralentissement du
développement du photovoltaïque comp
tenu du coût d'approche du matériel et
de l'étroitesse du marché par ailleurs
un projet de d'installation d'une
turbine de production d'électricité
couplée à notre usine d'incinération des
ordures tarde à se
réaliser le ministre de l'outremè lors
de sa visite à saint-barteléi le 16
octobre dernier a annoncé qu'il
plaiderait pour un coup de rachat
d'énergie par EDF autour de 350 € du
mgawh quel est votre avis sur ce sujet
seriez-vous favorable à le défendre
auprès de la
creux merci Micheline Patricia
chil quel serait V vos engagements en
tant que PDG de DF pour accompagner les
aider les collectivités local face à la
hausse des prix de
l'électricité après quelles sont vos
perspectives pour la Business unite
deedf à savoir EDF sei qui travaille
dans les zones non interconnectées corp
soutreem î île du Ponant pour accélérer
le déploiement des ENR et atteindre
l'autonomie énergétique merci merci
beaucoup Patricia Rémy Cardon et pour
terminer Laurent
sa merci madame la
Présidente question très simple que
pensez-vous de la de la stratégie de de
l'État français avec la facture un peu
salée des 24 milliards qui comprend
effectivement 10 milliards de manque à
gagner sur les recettes fiscales pour
l'électricité 6 milliards de dépenses
pour le gaz et
7, 5 milliards de remise à la pompe pour
le carburant en réalité quelle
efffficacité derrière si on y regarde
avec ce chiffre de 24 milliards quand le
fait que l'État finance donc autant un
couple retraité qui chauffe sa piscine
qu'un travailleur modeste qui maintient
sa température de son salon à 19°gr pour
le début de l'hiver de plus dans le
Bouclier
tarifaire il y a une réelle difficulté
il y a des grands oubliers si je parle
notamment des entreprises et des
collectivités qui n'ont plus accès au
tarifs réglementés en suite à
l'application des règles européennes de
la concurrence donc quelle est votre
feuille de route sur ce bouclier
tarifaire et qu'est-ce que vous proposez
pour redresser la
barre merci et enfin Laurent saumon oui
madame madame la Présidente vous avez
dit dans votre propos liminire monsieur
que la situation financière obligef
effectivement avoir une stratégie sur
les investissements mais aussi une
vision sur la régulation des prix comme
vous êtes un observateur extérieur
encore jusqu'à aujourd'hui quel conseil
stratégique avez-vous posé comme
condition au gouvernement pour cette
régulation des prix et pour pouvoir
permettre à F de se développer sur ses
investissements voilà Monsieur Raymond
l'ensemble des questions certaines sont
très précises certaines sont plus
stratégiques je vais vous laisser y
répondre certaines sont peut-être pas de
votre voilà domaine de compétence mais
je vous laisse y répondre merci beaucoup
mesdam madame la Présidente merci
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
les sénatrices je vais essayer de
répondre à toutes vos questions euh et
et j'espère que vous ne m'en voudrez pas
si j'en oublie un peu mais de toute
façon je reviendrai vers vous avec des
réponses plus précises euh alors je je
vais les reprendre dans l'ordre si vous
le voulez bien alors monsieur tisso me
demande ce
si si si mon passé détermine mon
[Rires]
avenir alors Monsieur tisso J'ai j'ai
j'ai fait beaucoup de choses comme tout
le monde j'ai pas fait des bonnes choses
mais il y a une chose qui est claire
c'est que tout ce que j'ai fait je l'ai
fait avec le le souhait le sentiment de
de trouver les voies et moyens pour les
entre is avec lesqueles j'étais en
relation ou dont j'avais la charge de
développer leur activité ça a toujours
été ma direction ça a toujours été ce
qui m'a ce qui m'a déterminé j'ai été
formé pour ça j'ai eu des mentors comme
Francis Mer que j'ai cité tout à l'heure
grand industriel qui m'ont expliqué qui
m'ont appris comment comment fonder le
développement d'une entreprise et
comment ensuite travailler pour trouver
les voies financières et techniques pour
le développement de ces entreprises et
dans certaines circonstances ça amène à
aller chercher des actionnaires
diversifiés dans d'autres ça peut amener
à travailler avec un seul actionnaire et
ben il se trouve que cette fois-ci je
vais travailler avec un seul actionnaire
le plus probablement puisque c'est le
projet de l'état de devenir actionnaire
à 100 % c'est un actionnaire de long
terme et je pense que dans les
circonstances du moment qui sont la
relance d'un plan d'investissement qui
nécessite une vision de long terme je
pense que c'est un moment utile pour
l'entreprise d'avoir un actionnaire de
long terme qui permet d'être son
interlocuteur pour aborder nouveau cycle
de vie de l'entreprise
euh monsieur
gay vous vous m'interpellez sur les SMR
je vous remercie ah pardon monsieur
excusez-moi j'ai j'ai parfois j'ai j'ai
du mal à à reporter au fur à mesure
monsieur vous m'avez interpellé sur les
smmr alors je je je crois beaucoup je
vais pas faire un trop long
développement sur la nouvelle filière
parce que ça le mériterait il y a
beaucoup de leçons à tirer des premiers
prototypes qui ont été construits sur
les deux dernières décennies avec des
difficultés industrielles difficultés de
chantier et cetera je pense que c'est
ces leçons sont en train d'être tirées
ça fait déjà plusieurs années que EDF
travaille sur sur les leçons apprises à
la foisk flamandville in point pour
lancer pour se préparer à lancer
maintenant la deuxème génération de PR
avec un objectif
d'industrialisation mais je crois qu'il
est souhaitable d'avoir dans cette
filière comme dans d'autres un
portefeuil de solutions qui permettent
de s'adapter aux besoins des des clients
et des pays donc pour la France comme
pour l'étranger même si les SMR sont pas
au même niveau de développement bien sûr
que la filière PR2 pour la France comme
pour l'étranger je pense qu'il est
souhaitable d'avoir cette filière SMR
qui bénéficie vous l'avez dit du
savoir-faire récurrent accumulé
notamment dans la filière propulsion
navale pour avoir un portefeuille
d'option pour servir à la fois le pays
et les prospect à l'export avec
différents types de puissance et
différents types de réacteurs donc
évidemment je me consacrerai à faire en
sorte que ce projet aille de
l'avant alors ensuite j'ai oublié du
coup de noter ce que m'avit dit Monsieur
Guay mais votre position sur l'AR sur
lauuration et la dette et la
dette je crois il me semble pourtant
avoir été clair sur ce que j'avais dit
sur la reen c'est un mécanisme à bout de
souffle qui CER a permis de
stabiliser les prix ou en tout cas de
préserver les en français d'une hausse
excessive de prix dans l'environnement
actuel mais pour autant évidemment le
deuxième objectif de laarè qui était de
créer une concurrence réelle n'est pas
atteint puisquil y a pas
d'investissement en dehors de en dehors
de DF clairement et donc il faut
réformer ce système j'ai été assez clair
làdessus est-ce que à ce stade n'étant
pas encore dans l'entreprise je peux
vous dire exactement come il faut le
faire non c'est trop tôt j'ai besoin de
travailler dessus avec avec les équipes
de DF mais je c'est bien orientation que
je prendrai dans mes discussions avec
les pouvoirs publics euh mon madame Bert
madame Bert voilà vous m'interpelliez
sur sur les 84 % et sur
l'hydroélectricité donc sur les 84
% je pense que vraiment nous sommes dans
une phase dans lequel EDF doit être
capable de tirer à long terme euh
dépasser évidemment les les difficultés
du moment qui sont des difficultés
opérationnelles et et et reprendre un
niveau de production élevé mais être
capable de regarder à long terme et pour
cela avoir un seul actionnaire ça
simplifie la capacité de regarder à long
terme sur l'hydroélectricité vous vous
l'avez tout à fait justement
souligné je ne connais pas encore tous
les détail du disposit ENF des des
différentes options juridiques
techniques et cetera qui sont
nécessaires à à la pérenisation de
l'activité hydroélectrique cette
pérénisation est nécessaire elle
correspond à la volonté des pouvoirs
publics à la volonté du gouvernement
exprimé également donc je travaillerai
sur les modalités techniques précises le
plus rapidement possible pour trouver un
accord sur les dispositions qui
permettent à EDF de poursuivre son
activité hydroélectrique et donner la
perspective de long terme là aussi dans
les relations avec les collectivités
locales qui sont évidemment un
partenaire absolument essentiel de cette
activité euh
ensuite monsieur buis vous m'avez euh
mvavez demandé comment on pouvait passer
de l'introduction en Bourse à la
renationalisation bah il faut en toute
chose un peu de flexibilité puis avec
l'âge on finit par murir et et et et par
considérer que voilà il y a pas de
direction absolu et que ce qui compte
c'est de faire avancer l'entreprise
voilà donc c'est dans cet état d'esprit
que je m'inscris euh sur la relance du
nucléire sur la pénurie de main d'œuvre
vous avez tout à fait raison bon il y a
déjà des mesures qui sont engagées et et
et ça couvre bien toute l'échelle hein
c'estàd que c'est le problème c'est pas
de trouver que des ingénieurs faut
trouver des soudeurs et un soudeur
nucléaire ça prend 3 ans à former donc
euh donc on parle bien de métier de
métier industriel c'est une
problématique que je connais bien dans
mon métier actuel parce que trouver des
électriciens en France je peux vous dire
c'est le même problème donc euh donc
dans dans mon métier actuel euh nous
faisons l'effort de former euh euh je
crois une dizaine de milliers
d'électriciens euh chaque année en
France euh pour que ce métier attire et
ce métier perdure euh je sais que dans
l'industrie navale par exemple dont
j'étais administrateur euh l'industrie
navale a pris l'initiative de lancer
toute une série d'écoles de formation à
tous les niveaux ouvriers qualifiés
technicien euh et ingénieur parce que
c'est indispensable donc le nucléaire a
pris la même direction au travers du
jfen notamment et je soutiendrai ces
mesures et même j'en prendrai la tête
parce que je pense que le le le monde
professionnel a besoin de de voir toute
la filière mobilisée a besoin de voir le
PDG de DF à la tête de ces sujetsl euh
sans quoi il y a pas de filière
industrielle et s'il y a pas de filière
industrielle on ile les délais et le
temps est notre principal ennemi dans
dans tout ça euh madame
Artigalas vous m'avez posé la question
sur les concessions hydroélectriques
donc j'ai besoin de travailler sur le
sujet comme je l'ai comme je viens de
l'expliquer mais c'est évidemment un
élément absolument clé du programme
stratégique de DF et de la volonté
gouvernementale de pérénniser cette
activité au sein de DF donc je
travaillai dans cette direction je peux
pas vous donner toutes les modalités
aujourd'hui parce que je ne les ai pas
encore mais ça fera partie de mes sujets
de travail immédiat bien sûr
euh madame JAC gquer pardon excusez-moi
je suis désolé
euh vous m'avez interpellé sur le coût
pour les
ménages alors c'est un sujet délicat
évidemment parce que finalement nous
sommes dans une situation dans laquelle
depuis 20 30
ans les les 58 réacteurs nous permettent
d'avoir une énergie très
compétitive et il faut que nous
abordions maintenant un cycle dans
lequel nous préparons l'avenir et dans
ce si qui prépare l'avenir ben tout le
monde va devoir y mettre du sien
l'entreprise en étant performante ça
c'est une partie de mon travail c'est
même l'essentiel de mon travail si vous
le voulez bien ensuite euh bah la nation
dans le sens où la nation contribue au
renouvellement de cette capacité mais
les clients ou les usagers comme vous
préférez évidemment devront participer
et et je rappelle que le parc de 58
réacteurs il a été financé sans aucun ou
avec très très peu ou pratiquement sans
aucun financement public et donc ce sont
les clients qui l' qui l'ont financé ils
l'ont financé simplement en évitant je
crois que ce qui est le plus important
c'est d'éviter les fluctuations
complètement exagérer des prix c'est ça
qui est qui est totalement
destructeur mais le fait que nous
financions ou que les clients financent
le coût complet y compris le cycle aval
et je fais le lien avec votre deuxième
question qui est le traitement des
déchets ça c'est une nécessité pour la
pérénité de la filière donc oui
naturellement je je suis très attentif
au sujet de l'aval et au sujet du
traitement des déchets je ne connais pas
encore tous les éléments des projets
parce que il y a beaucoup de choses à à
apprendre et à redécouvrir à découvrir
quand on est encore à l'extérieur de
l'entreprise mais c'est bien un des
piliers essentiels de la pérénité de la
filière et c'est bien sur l'ensemble du
cycle y compris des constructions que je
travaillerai avec les équipes de DF et
les entreprises et les instituts ou
organisations publiques qui travaillent
dessus pour nous assurer de la cohérence
de l'ensemble de la filière sur
l'ensemble du
cycle
madame VO si je mélange les feuilles en
plus ça va paser alors madame
F
vous m'avez demandé quelle serait ma
méthode pour prendre en compte les
résultats de la
concertation c'est une excellente
question madame
et bon la concertation elle concerne à
la fois les pouvoirs publics bien sûr et
l'entreprise donc le résultat de la
concertation il va devoir être pris en
compte par le gouvernement et également
par l'entreprise donc la seule réponse
que je puisse vous faire à ce stade
c'est que c'est évidemment un des sujets
essentiel que je vais discuter avec le
gouvernement pour prendre en
considération le résultat de la
concertation et et voir quels sont les
les les suites à donner mais ça peut pas
être une prise en compte uniquement par
l'entreprise c'est c'est ça que je veux
vous dire
euh monsieur
du pardon excusez- j'ai peur de du plomb
voilà j'ai j'ai peur d'écorcher les noms
donc ah oui monsieur duplom qui m'avait
interpellé don qui qui m'a qui m'a dit
qu'il me donnerai sa voix et je lui en
en suis
reconnaissantre alors alors qui en
général entre ce alors qu' alors qu'il
était beaucoup plus circonspect au début
donc je je vous en
remercie l'exemple que vous citez est
évidemment saisissant évidemment
saisissant je n'ai pas à l'heure où nous
parlons la
solution je sais qu'il y a des
situations comme ceci ça ne me satisfait
pas je sais que DF travaille main dans
la main avec le gouvernement pour
trouver un maximum de solutions
possiblebles et et il y en a qui sortent
tous les jours donc j'ai même du mal à
les suivre à ce stade parce que voilà ça
ça veut dire quand même la la on dire la
dimension critique du sujet est bien
prise en compte par tout le monde voilà
euh je n'ai pas de baguette magique à
forurer parce que je ne suis pas encore
dans l'entreprise mais ce que je peux
vous dire c'est qu'évidemment ça sera ma
ma ma préoccupation immédiate voilà
après EDF doit travailler dans les
règles de marché qui lui sont fixé mais
on voilà je ferai avec le gouvernement
tout ce qu'on peut euh voilà moi mes
clients d'aujourd'hui hein sont dans le
monde entier des PME hein donc notamment
donc je je sais ce que c'est
euh merci beaucoup euh monsieur
menénouville Menonville menénonville
pardon menénonville excusez-moi
euh déploiement sur le territoire des
différents pr bon là aussi là aussi
c'est ça relève de la concertation hein
je pense évidemment avec avec le
gouvernement avec les autorités locales
avec les
collectivités il y a des des
problématiques d'autorisation
naturellement qu'il faudra qu'il faudra
prendre en considération euh là aussi
j'insiste sur la dimension temps
euh j'ai rappelé la performance de nos
anciens 58 réacteurs en 20 ans euh je ne
pense pas que nous soyons capable
aujourd'hui en tant que nation de
déployer 58 réacteurs en 20 ans pour des
raisons industrielles et ça ça me
regarde largement avec toute la filière
mais aussi pour des raisons de de ce que
nous sommes en tant que nation en terme
de capacité à construire et donc donc
là-dessus j'aurais besoin de tout le
monde vraiment pour pour être capable de
répondre à à l'exigence de nouvelles
capacités qui sont nécessaires pour
accompagner l'électrification et le
renouvellement du parc donc je sais
qu'il y a des travaux qui sont en cours
et que vous vous y avez passé d'ailleurs
une partie de la nuit si j'ai bien
compris sur les énergie renouvelable
mais ça touche tous les domaines et
évidemment le nucléaire aussi
euh vous m'avez parlé de 6Go c'est un
projet que je connais seulement un peu à
ce stade mais qui est absolument
critique bien sûr et donc je feraiis
tout le nécessaire pour le découvrir
dans les détails et pour être certain
que pour ce qui concerne DF nous y
participions de façon active euh madame
blatrix euh vous m'avez interrogé sur
l'international et sur incle point euh
alors incle point est un projet très
important pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
parce qu'il est important pour le
Royaume-Uni dans l'équilibre futur du
parc nucléaire du Royaume-Uni important
pour EDF qui est un gros acteur au
royaume i et évidemment de la même façon
que nous avons besoin de préparer
l'avenir en France EDF étant un acteur
important au Royaume-Uni nous avons
besoin de préparer l'avenir au
Royaume-Uni c'est aussi important pour
la filière parce que Inle point arrive
en terme d'activité à un moment de creux
d'activité et quand vous avez pas
d'activité dans une filière ben vous
détruisez la filière industrielle donc
in point est très important de ce point
de vue là aussi et donc évidemment je je
m'y rendrai et je suivrai le projet de
près comme tous les projets il peut
avoir des aléa et des difficultés et
nous y ferons face et nous les
relèverons
euh voilà ensuite la relation avec
l'Allemagne vous interroger sur la
relation avec l'Allemagne je pense c'est
un point très important et et et nous le
voyons d'ailleurs dans les discussions
quasi quotidiennes qui qui animent
aujourd'hui les les discussions
intergouvernementales et européennes je
crois vraiment et c'est ça correspond à
l'expression du gouvernement et du
président de la République que nous
devons construire un un nouveau
consensus énergétique avec l'Allemagne
il y a des divergences elles sont
claires mais je c'est vraiment très
important pour l'avenir du marché
électrique européen que ces divergences
soient exprimé à plan pour que nous
arrivions à créer un nouveau consensus
européen sur l'électricité notamment
mais sur l'énergie plus
généralement monsieur
merou vous vous m'avez demandé que si
j'arrivais
avec un plan
vous avez dit ultralibéral je
crois écoutez je suis je me souviens
d'unun de mes collègues qui m'avait dit
je suis surtout ultra humaniste c'est
c'est c'est ça qui me définit mieux que
ultralibéral je crois à l'entreprise il
y a pas de doute là-dessus je crois à la
réussite de
l'entreprise et je crois que je crois
que l'entreprise se développe par les
projets qu'elle forme elle-même et et et
qu'elle conduit à la réussite par sa
capacité à les mener à bien voilà voilà
ce à quoi je crois euh je n'arrive pas
avec un plan qui m'est défini et
j'arrive avec le mandat de faire réussir
EDF voilà mon mandat
euh monsieur
montoger vous m'avez posé la question de
mon mandat aussi donc je pense que je
peux vous faire à peu près la même
réponse je n'ai pas l'habitude de
raisonner sur les organisations avant
d'avoir raisonné sur
l'objectif je pense que c'est un
raisonnement qui est à l'envers donc ce
que j'ai essayé de vous expliquer dans
mon propol ire c'est que ma vision d'un
opérateur
électrique qui réussit c'est c'est
quelqu'un c'est une entreprise qui
réussit à avoir trois métiers
fondamentaux qui sont le développement
de solutions pour les clients une
production diversifiée et les réseaux et
c'est bien dans dans la capacité d'avoir
ces trois métiers fondamentaux
fonctionnant en synergie au sein de DF
que je pense fonder la réussite future
de
DF
ors il y avait beaucoup
d'éléments
mais laarine je crois que j'ai je sou
suce qui se passe la question du
financement des
financement alors sur laaren je crois
avoir répondu à certains de vos
collègues sur le financement du nouveau
nucléaire notamment il y a du travail à
faire il faut inscrire financement du
nouveau nucléaire dans une perspective
de long terme qui qui concerne bien sûr
EDF au premier chef mais qui doit
permettre d'avoir cette vision de long
terme qui est indispensable au au cycle
du nucléaire donc j'ai besoin de
travailler je reviendrai vous voir une
fois que j'aurai
une des modalités qui sont qui sont
arrêtées et qui sont partagé
naturellement avec le gouvernement et
probablement la Commission européenne
aussi euh madame estr Sasson vous m'avez
interrogé sur la publicité o jusqu'à
quand je ne sais pas je suis très
heureux d'avoir reçu moi-même la
proposition d'adhérer à O ce que je vais
faire bien sûr euh vous m'avez interrogé
sur les fraudes à laarè qui m'interpelle
autant que vous clairement je pense
c'est un des c'est un un des signes que
que l'AREN est est un dispositif qui
fondamentalement ne fournit qu'une
option gratuite à un certain nombre de
commercialisateurs qui peuvent le cas
échéant même en abuser donc nous
suivrons attentivement euh les résultats
de l'enquête de la creux et le cas
échéant évidemment euh je regarderai ce
qu'il convient de faire d'un point de
vue juridique de la part de DF euh
monsieur salmon vous m'avez interrogé
sur euh euh sur le niveau de la dette
euh sur le coût complet du nucléaire
réel honnêtement je ne sais pas
aujourd'hui je suis pas dedans donc
c'est évidemment une des questions
essentielles que je me poserai dès que
je suis dans l'entreprise pour m'assurer
que dans les discussions futures ce soit
naturellement bien pris en compte sur
les dispositifs de
régulation vous m'avez interrogé sur les
piscines j'ai compris que c'était les
piscines
nucléaires et donc je vous fais la même
réponse qui que je suis bien conscient
qui a un sujet aval euh et je vais
travailler sur le sujet aval évidemment
euh et enfin vous m'avez interrogé sur
la gigafactory annoncé par nel je pense
qu'il y a il y a matière à réfléchir à
l'échelle européenne hein sur euh de
même qu'on le fait sur les
semi-conducteurs je suis très sensible
au sujet semi-conducteur parce que je
suis euh je suis fabricant de matériel
électromécanique ou électronique aussi
euh donc l'Europe se structure
maintenant euh en terme de capacité
industrielle dans les semi-conducteurs
je pense qu'il est souhaitable qu'une
réflexion équivalente existe pas
seulement sur les panneaux
photovoltaïques mais sur un certain
nombre de composants critiques qui sont
sur la chaîne électrique on peut parler
des batteries ça existe déjà on peut
parler d'un certain nombre de de
dispositifs électronique et cetera donc
donc c'est plus large mais je pense
qu'il y a besoin d'une réflexion
européenne sur ces sujetsl monsieur
l'abbé vous m'avez interrogé sur la
production
d'hydrogène et sur la sobriété euh alors
sur la production d'hydrogène c'est
effectivement une filière d'avenir elle
est pas à stade de maturité aujourd'hui
EDF travaille dessus je vais découvrir
quels sont les différents axes de DF
plus en plus en détail de ce que j'ai pu
voir dans mes dans mes activités
actuelles il y a un certain nombre de
finalités de l'hydrogène qui trouvent
plus naturellement leur marché que
d'autres aujourd'hui donc vous avez des
des activités industrielles de
l'hydrogène notamment pour lesquels il
est il est il est plus naturel et
souhaitable d'aller plus vite parce
qu'elle trouve naturellement leur
finalit dans l'exploitation euh ce sera
probablement plus difficile de faire
électricité vers hydrogène vers
électricité ça je pense que c'est le le
rendement de ce process là est encore
relève plus de la RD à ce stade qu'autre
chose mais mais en tout cas votre votre
préoccupation est partagée sur
l'hydrogène sur le fait que ça constitue
une filière d'avenir sur laquelle EDF
doit être présent alors je suis un peu
déçu que vous n'ayez pas entendu mon
plidoyer pour la sobriété parce que s'il
y a bien un sujet sur lequel bien avant
d'être candidat à la présidence de DF je
je travaille tous les jours c'est la
sobriété et l'efficacité énergétique qui
est l'un des crédaux de l'entreprise qui
m'emploi aujourd'hui euh et donc dans
dans tous les pays du monde et avant
cela en France euh quand je m'occupais
de la France j'ai toujours eu pour
préoccupation d'apporter des solutions
techniques pour que euh les utilisateurs
les usagers euh de l'électricité et
d'autres types d'énergie puissent
choisir leur mode de consommation de
façon à améliorer leur sobriété et et
pour vous donner un
exemple pour avoir
maintenant fréquenter
physiquement les les installations
industrielles
tertièes voir résidentiel même de
particulier dans dans beaucoup beaucoup
de pays je sais par expérience que 10 à
15 % de de sobriété est est un objectif
qui se fait sans douleur statistiquement
c'est qu'il est possible de réduire sa
consommation de 10 à 15 % sans en sans
en sentir les effets sur son bien-être
et donc ça ça c'est une statistique
c'est c'est pas c'est pas juste une
intuition c'est quelque chose qui est
prouvé statistiquement et que avec un
effort notamment dans les dans les
domaines professionnels c'est là où vous
avez des des personnes qui s'occupent de
la sobriété à l'intérieur même des
entreprises 30 à 50 % n'est pas hors de
portée a sans et que généralement
d'ailleurs ces obj objectif là sont
également des éléments qui concourent à
la performance économique des acteurs
donc voilà j'espère qu'avec ça j'aurais
été un peu plus complet sur la sobriété
et et de vous dire que y compris
vis-à-vis au travers des capacités de DF
lui-même donc ces capacités commerciales
avec les conseils de DF dans les
différentes régions ou au travers de
Dalia dont c'est la mission je compte
bien que DF uvre dans ce domaine madame
Loisier vous m'avez interrogé madame
Loisier
alors vous m'avez dit comment ne pas
retomber après tout
ça ben je pense que ça sera juste
beaucoup de travail et pas seulement
j'aurais besoin de beaucoup d'aide aussi
de la part
de de tout le monde
voilà vous m'avez parlé de la main
d'œuve qualifiée je crois que j'y ai un
peu répondu déjà mais mais clairement
c'est un des éléments absolument
critiques de succès et donc ça commence
ça commence au collège ça commence au
collège je pense c'est pas plus tard que
ça pour les électriciens on a commencé
au collège pour commencer vraiment à
attirer les gens vers les métiers
techniqu sont des métiers qui sont
nobles bien payés qui sont qui sont dans
lesqueles on se réalise parce qu'on
fabrique quelque chose et donc il faut
réattirer vers ces métiers là et ça fait
partie je pense des conditions de
succès vous m'avez parlé du pilotage
numérique et de la vulnérabilité c'est
un sujet qui qui me tient
particulièrement à cœur parce que c'est
mon métier d'aujourd'hui
euh j'ai j'ai contribué à équiper des
des réseaux électriques dans le monde
entier depuis depuis 8 9 ans maintenant
évidemment la première préoccupation
tous les réseaux électriques à juste
titre et la vulnérabilité numérique il y
a des solutions bien sûr pour rendre
plus robuste et pour rendre robuste tout
système intégré sur le plan numérique
ces solutions doivent être régulièrement
améliorées parce que évidemment la
menace change de nature mais c'est
quelque chose sur sur lequel j'aurai
l'occasion de revenir si vous le
souhaitez de façon plus détaillée une
autre fois mais c'est un élément
absolument clé dans la façon
dont les don EDF d'une part en tant
qu'intégrateur et systémier et
utilisateur mais également toutes les
tous les autres opérateurs électriques
que je connais travaillent et la façon
dont les opérateurs tels que Schneider
électrique et les autres naturellement
travaillent pour améliorer la robustesse
des systèmes et faire en sorte que euh
l'indispensable flexibilité du réseau
qui doit intégrer le caractère
bidirectionnel que je décrivait tout à
l'heure puisse se faire en toute
robustesse euh sécurité numérique
euh Rena garabédian madame Renault
garabédian m'a interrogé sur
euh sur la géothermie et
sur et sur la cybersécurité aussi alors
je ne sais pas si ma réponse vous
satisfait à l'instant sur la
géothermie
alors il y a plusieurs volet de la
géothermie hein parce que à la fin une
pompe à chaleur c'est aussi un peu de la
la géothermie
simple donc ce potentiel est clairement
sous-exploité vous avez raison
aujourd'hui pour moi il a il y a deux
potentiels sous-exploités aujourd'hui en
France et en Europe par rapport à ce que
je peut voir ailleurs dans le monde le
potentiel de production électrique en
autoconsommation et sousexpl
clairement et c'est une façon de créer
de la capacité à moindre coût
collectif en terme de génération
centralisée donc c'est une c'est un axe
sur lequel je pense qu'il y a une
capacité en gigawatt potentiel qui peut
être qui peut être créé dans une période
de temps relativement courte j'ai des
exemples de pays en tête qui ont suivi
cette direction parce qu'il n'avait pas
le choix il n'avait pas non plus la
chance d'avoir un parc centralisé
compétitifs nucléair comme nous donc
c'est un premier axe le deuxième axe
c'est évidemment l'exploitation
géothermique alors avec probablement des
différences selon la nature des
géographies et la nature de la densité
parce que évidemment en géothermie si
vous voulez avoir une exploitation gé
thmique industrielle il vous faut une
densité de clientèle qui justifie de
réseau ça c'est un investissement en
capital qui est assez élevé alors que si
vous êtes simplement dans du
pavillonnaire isolé la la voie la plus
simple de la géothermie finalement même
si c'est pas vraiment de la géothermie
c'est une pompe à chaleur et donc dans
ces deux axes là je pense que il y a un
potentiel qui va croître et auquel nous
pouvons
contribuer madame Jacques vous m'avez
interrogé sur le coût de rachat de
l'énergie injecté dans le réseau
euh que vous estimez trop faible à
saint-bartelemi et et en et en Outremer
je n'ai pas une réponse précise à vous
faire à ce stade je pense que ça ne vous
survendra pas complètement naturellement
je regarderai ça et je reviens viendrai
vers vous et sur la cogénération qui
tarde à se réaliser j'ai j'ai bien pris
note ce que je veux vous dire c'est que
j'ai par mes par mon mon travail depuis
quelques années j'ai travaillé avec
beaucoup de territoires insulaires y
compris les départements et territoires
d'outrem français que je
connais les les défis particuliers à ce
type de géographie pour ce qui concerne
l'énergie à la fois l'énergie en en
production centralisée souvent carboné
bien sûr mais aussi le potentiel de de
de produit décentralisé qui permet à ces
territoires généralement de changer
assez radicalement leur profil
électrique euh et donc je travaillerai
avec les équipe de DF pour que nous
puissions trouver des solutions adaptées
à chaque territoire euh madame
chilinger vous m'avez interpellé sur le
prix de l'électricité pour les
collectivités auquel je suis extrêmement
sensible alors il y a évidemment
beaucoup de situations de collectivités
différentes il une grande partie euh les
plus petites jusqu'à euh jusqu'à 10
salariés si ma mémoire est bonne et
jusqu'à quelques millions de budgets 2
millions de budget si ma mémoire est
bonne qui sont éligible au au TRV je
crois comprendre que le gouvernement a
accepté de relever le seuil de
consommation de ces de ces collectivités
au-dessus de 36 kVA pour pour permettre
qu'elle reste au TRV je sais qu'il y il
y a depuis hier un deuxème dispositif
qui permet aux collectivités de moins de
250 personnees euh de de dispos de de de
bénéficier d'un soutien gouvernemental
j'en connais pas tous les détails parce
que ça date d'hier euh et au-delà de ça
évidemment euh EDF et et souhaite je je
être à à la disposition et répondre au
mieux aux besoins des collectivités
j'ignore pas les difficultés de EDF
frera tous sont possiblees dans le casre
des règles de marché qui s'appliquent à
EDF bien sûr euh pour pour atténuer les
difficultés que je ne méconnais pas
euh monsieur Cardon vous m'avez
interrogé sur euh alors je suis pas sûr
d'avoir complètement compris votre
question parce que vous aviez à la fois
la partie électrique la part enfin la
partie énergétique au sens large
euh euh donc je pense que votre question
s'adresse plus au gouvernement qu'au
futur Président Directeur Général desdfe
éventuel mais euh bien sûr je pense dans
les circonstances présentes il est clair
que le le coût de l'énergie à un coût
global et et mon souci en tant que
dirigeant d'entreprise sera de faire en
sorte que ce que nous devons faire pour
le court terme n'oberre pas l'avenir
voilà parce que nous avons besoin de
travailler sur le long terme en même
temps voilà ce que moi je peux dire en
vu du point de vue de l'entreprise euh
euh
ensuite
monsieur monsieur saumon voilà vous
m'avez interrogé sur le scénario en
nombre des réacteurs
et sur le mode de financement et sur les
compétences alors sur sur le nombre de
réacteurs je veux pas vous paraître
timoré mais je vais être
prudent parce que je je ne pense pas
qu'à ce stade notre principal défi en
tant qu'entreprise soit soit juste de
dire un nombre de réacteurs je pense
notre principal défi c'est d'arriver à
faire en sorte que nous montions une
filière industrielle qui permett un
coout récurrent du réacteur le plus
faible possible et un délai de
construction du réacteur le plus faible
possible une fois qu'on aura mis en
chantier cette filière industrielle qui
est vraiment le défi de le PR2 euh le
nombre de réacteurs devient un sujet qui
est adaptable euh et il sera adapté je
pense euh sur la durée aux besoins du
pays euh et donc plutôt que de formuler
le problème en disant euh c'est c'est
pas 6 c'est 14 mon attitude consiste à
dire bah il faut se lancer dans cette
dans dans dans cette euh dans ce
chantier qui est très important avec une
vision industrielle qui permet d'en
assurer le succès et le succès il est
financier industriel et humain et pour
ça il nous faut assurer la réalisation
de le Pr récurrent même du tandem de PR
parce que je pense qu'on il y a un
mérite comme ça a été fait dans le passé
d'en faire deux à la fois sur le même
site pour faire en sorte que ce soit
compétitif voilà ensuite vous m'avez
interrogé
sur juste que c'était pas la question
j'ais posé merci pour la rép ah
pardon gverement en TER de régulation
des la politique
réulationeé désolé si j'ai mal reporté
les
questions la salle
[Musique]
long dire c'était euh
euh
écoutez je je pense qu'il y a il y a un
volet européen qui est vraiment
indispensable il faut bouger les lignes
au niveau européen parce que les les les
les points faibles de la régulation
européenne sont visible aujourd'hui donc
il est indispensable de bouger les
lignes donc c'est ce que j'ai cité tout
à l'heure
c'est-à-dire pas assez de d'incitation à
l'investissement trop de court terme
dans la régulation européenne pas assez
de flexibilité donc pas assez de
capacité de gérer du contrat de long
terme notamment ça si on ne bouge pas
les lignes là-dessus et puis évidemment
la décorrélation gaz et si on bouge pas
les lignes là-dessus on peut essayer de
faire tout ce qu'on veut à l'échelle
nationale on restera dans un dispositif
qui est intrinsèquement instable et qui
ne regarde que le court terme et qui ne
favorise pas l'investissement donc ça
c'est vraiment le je pense c'est le
c'est la pierre angulaire de ce qu'il
faut faire j'ai le sentiment que les
autorités françaises euh en sont plus
que conscientes et on ont déjà engager
euh le la discussion avec les les les
autres membres de de l'Union sur ce
sujet et avec la Commission européenne
le travail de DF là-dessus c'est d'être
un conseil et un sachant finalement du
marché parce que le sachant du marché
est normalement celui qui est bien placé
pour dire là ça va là ça va pas donc
voilà ce que j'essaierai de faire
j'espère que ça répond à votre question
est-ce que j'ai oublié une question je
ne crois pas et et je et je vais
même si ça a été répondu me semble-t-il
VO voilà je je vais je vais vous
remercier Monsieur Raymond pour
l'ensemble de vos questions je vais
couper évidemment l'audition très
rapidement car vous êtes attendu dans un
quart d'ure à l'Assemblée nationale que
nous avons prévenu de votre retard donc
voilà merci beaucoup nous allons de
notre côté procéder au vote et je vous
tiendrai bien sûr informé merci madame
la Présidente merci à toutes et à tous
[Musique]
et si vous me le si vous me confirmez je
serai heureux de poursuivre ces
discussions naturellement
régulièrement très bien merci j'invite
mes collègues à rester dans la salle
évidemment pour
procéder